[Music]
the city is for some glamorous
stimulating prosperous
only recently has it become dangerous
[Music]
Jack I think I found something three
women were strangled over the last two
weeks you're on the lifestyle desk
you're not covering a homicide I think
the murders are connected
the woman was strangled just came over
the wire I'm killing the follow-up you
don't have a story how many women have
to die before it's a story worry
they just confirmed number four
police aren't talking never seen him
this tight-lipped about anything I don't
care if it's one killer of four we're
gonna catch whoever did this
Boston police hands on the wall we had
him we just let him walk away
everything lines up with him his history
the progression of the crimes everything
you know how many people have gone down
the rabbit hole with
it's a dead end every time in this case
what do you think you're gonna find out
there when is this gonna stop Loretta I
need you to call in a favor be quick I
don't want to get fired tonight
any lawyer worth a dime would pick this
apart
[Music]
you really want to use this paper to
tear down the police department if
anyone else was blowing it this badly
we'd have put it on the front page a
long time ago and he used to take down
an address if I don't call back in an
hour give it to the police Loretta
there's more than one lunatic out there
and you're going to get us both killed
safe little world is just delusion
foreign
[Music]